In 2005, two researchers published a series
of articles investigating the subject of other
people’s smelliness.
They examined how much disgust people would
feel and show after smelling a variety of
odors, including armpits, garbage and farts.
Among the stinks examined, farts elicited
the strongest negative response, and across
all body odors, people consistently rated
odors of other people worse than their own
(with one notable exception in that the armpit
sweat of one’s partner was generally rated
as less offensive than a person’s own.
For why this might be the case, see: Why Do
We Still Have Pubic and Armpit Hair)
This all leaves us with the question of why
other people’s farts smell worse.
Probably the leading reason your own farts
aren’t generally as offensive to your nose
is that you’re used to your own smell.
The more you’re used to something, like
a smell, the more likely you are to, if not
prefer it, at least to partially tune it out
consciously, making it less extreme to
your senses.
As you’re smelling yourself all day, every
day, your brain tunes out some of the smells
emanating from your pores, the surface of
your skin, and the air expelled from your
lungs, all creating a somewhat unique blend
of odors largely resulting from various microbes
that call your body home and, of course, what
you eat.
(Note: on average there are about 10 times
more bacterial cells in your guts alone than
human cells that make up your whole body.)
For example, if you eat a lot of garlic, even
if you brush your teeth and rinse with mouthwash
directly after, you’re still likely to smell
a bit to others who aren’t eating garlic,
but not so much to yourself.
This is because some of the sulfuric compounds
in the garlic get metabolized and make their
way into your blood stream.
Once they’re in your blood, they eventually
get passed out of your body through various
bodily excretions, which includes being exuded
through your pores and also passed into the
air that fills your lungs.
So not only does your whole body smell like
you’re wearing a stinky perfume, but, as
you breathe, the air goes into your lungs
and is contaminated by the allyl methyl sulfide;
this in turn causes your breath to continue
to smell even though you’ve cleaned your
mouth out.
Of course, you are typically unaware of any
of this, as your brain quickly tunes out the
odor emanating from yourself.
The same type of thing is happening, albeit
to a much lesser extent, with some of the
odors that make up your farts.
It has also been proposed that there is probably
some level of your brain tuning the smell
of your farts out for another reason- it expects
a potentially strong smell directly after
it knows you just farted.
While this may seem farfetched, it turns out
your brain does stuff like this all the time.
For instance, have you ever noticed that you
can’t tickle yourself?
(Well, most people can’t anyway.)
This is because your brain anticipates things
going on around you in order to help speed
up response times, among other reasons.
In the case of touch, more technically, the
cerebellum monitors body movements and can
also distinguish between expected sensations
and unexpected ones, generally resulting in
diminishing or completely discarding expected
sensations, while paying much more attention
to unexpected ones.
For instance, when you are typing on a keyboard,
your brain significantly dulls the touch sensation
in your fingertips so that you don’t really
notice it unless you consciously think about
it.
This same type of thing happens when you try
to tickle yourself.
Researchers at University College London tested
this by scanning the brains of subjects while
the palms of their hands were touched by themselves
and by experimenters.
The brain scans revealed that when the touch
was externally produced, the somatosensory
cortex (involved in processing touch) and
anterior cingulate cortex parts of the brain
reacted much more strongly than when the touch
was produced by the subjects themselves.
In these latter cases, the brain was using
information it has on hand such as motor movements
of the finger and arms to anticipate the touch.
In the extreme case, like when someone sneaks
up behind you and starts tickling your neck,
the sensation can be extremely strong, possibly
even resulting in you jumping out of your
chair and slapping the back of your neck before
you really even consciously register the touch.
This is a good thing.
You see, it turns out the panic response when
a tarantula is crawling on your leg or the
like is exactly what is happening in your
brain and body when you are getting tickled.
The body’s response to being tickled is
panic and anxiety.
It is thought that this is a defense mechanism
for exactly this type of thing where an external
touch, such as a venomous insect crawling
on you or the like, might be occurring.
The body needs to react quickly to this unanticipated
touch and without time for much conscious
thought, so produces the panic reaction.
(Interestingly, the panic reaction that results
from tickling doesn’t feel like tickling
when the person tickling you isn’t someone
you want to be doing this.
In this case, it more closely resembles actual
panic reactions, rather than having associated
laughter.)
In any event, the same exact thing is thought
to be happening with farts.
Your brain knows you just farted, so at least
partially tunes out the smell.
That said, when another person farts and you
definitely know they just did before the smell
hits you, it still seems to smell worse.
While it’s not wholly understood why this
is the case, it’s generally thought that
there are two factors at play.
First, there may be an element of confirmation
bias going on here.
Essentially, you remember the really stinky
farts from other people, but not so much the
numerous farts you take a whiff of daily that
don’t really smell at all (whether you knew
the person farted or not).
Second, we return to the aforementioned fact
that your brain isn’t tuning out foreign
smells necessarily like it does your own,
as well as the fact that our brains, for whatever
reason, seem geared to react more strongly
to negative smelling odors from others, even
if the fart in question contains more or less
the same levels of noxious fumes as your own.
There are important evolutionary reasons why
this is the case, even if the mechanism isn’t
wholly understood.
For instance, it is entirely possibly for
you to become infected with a disease from
smelling another person’s fart.
This isn’t so common anymore now that most
humans tend to walk around wearing underwear
and other garments on top of that, filtering
your rear expulsions a bit.
But, much like certain viruses and the like
can be transmitted via coughs, pathogens like
streptococcus pyogenes can be transmitted
to you via an improperly filtered fart where
the poop particles are peregrinating through
the air, perhaps ultimately ending up in your
nose, throat or lungs.
Your brain is seemingly built to be keenly
aware of this danger and so goes ahead and
reacts more negatively to said odoriferous
odor from an external source, just in case,
motivating you to want to leave the stinky
zone or at least hold your breath for a bit
while the air clears out.